attention vous allez avoir vous savez
quoi
vous allez avoir une interview cauchemar
en vigueur bien à terme cauchemar
qu'elle pourrait être pour vous
salvatore adamo le pire des accidents
conjugaux vous faire surprendre par
votre femme
quand vous êtes avec votre maîtresse
surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleure amie ou troisième solution
sûre pour en votre femme votre maîtresse
ensemble oui pense que ce serait su
reprendre ma femme dans les bras de
miami way lors où ça serait le pire
je pensais qu est le pire cadeau qu'on
puisse vous faire une perceuse sans fil
un abonnement dans un club de gym ou le
nouveau os et des dents à rillieux par
exemple on a une perceuse sans fil
mais la pire situation au quotidien pour
vous c'est d'avoir une cigarette mais
pas de feu d'avoir une carte bleue mais
pas de code ou d'avoir une fille canon
mais pas de préservatif allez la
dernière quand même
j'avertis ma femme que tout ça est
théorique n'est ce pas oui oui c'est ce
que voulait dit en rentrant elle aussi
sera déroulé ton meilleur ami à dire
c'est théorique est alors à une perceuse
sans fil
bravo
qu'elle pourrait quelques remous la pire
des illusions apprendre qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans casimir non thierry
lafond mettait des chaussettes dans son
collant que goldorak et doublé pour les
cascades awk chirac est mêlé à la sphère
des hlm de la ville de paris non je
pense que comme je crois encore au père
noël
apprendre d'un coup qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir ça vous le ver serait ma
fille il ya quelqu'un à chirac sait très
bien ce qu'est ce qui est pire pour vous
un portable qui sonne tout le temps qui
sonne jamais à qui sonne jamais le pire
c'est de grandir seul de vivre seul ou
de vieillir seul je pense que c'est
vieillir seul à avoir connu la compagnie
et puis se retrouver seul parce que si
on grandit selon as le temps de s'y
habituer
merci salvador
laurent je vais vous salue le oui c'est
très déçu parce que tu passes pour un
mec qui sait tout et tu te manque une
fiche sur salvatore et la particularité
anatomique et semble ignorer
il a 3 1 oui bravo thiriez et quand on
insiste il le montre
ni schuman excusez-moi quatre coups y
aller vite très vite je le savais mais
moi je suis quelqu'un de discret vous vu
quelqu'un j'ai rien à voir avec ce type
là d'ailleurs laurent ciao
demain